A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. Or on our website.
清凉的水花将流淌进你心灵深处。那些蔚蓝而澎湃的海浪能推动你前行，也能抚平你的心绪。漫步密歇根海岸。只需在此刻感受水流。让那些浩瀚的湖泊、河流和溪流留下永恒的回忆。纵身一跃，让纯净的密歇根之水洗涤你的心灵，尽在“纯粹密歇根”。请访问 Michigan.org 了解新鲜资讯。或访问我们的网站。
Today's episode deals with a crime committed against a child that won't be suitable for all listeners. Today, the district of Notting Hill in London's inner west is renowned as one of the city's more affluent areas. But in the late 1940s, it was not a desirable place to live. A number of its buildings had been damaged or completely ravaged during the Blitz, an intensive German bombing campaign during the Second World War that killed more than 40,000 civilians. Many of the larger houses that remained standing were sold to landlords who divided them into multi-occupancy dwellings, with tenants leasing either a room or a single story. Ten Rillington Place in Notting Hill's Ladbrook Grove neighborhood was one such abode.
今天的节目讲述了一起针对儿童的犯罪，可能并非适合所有听众。如今，伦敦内西区的诺丁山街区以其较富裕的区域而闻名。但在20世纪40年代末，这里并不是一个理想的居住地。在二战期间德国的密集轰炸行动“闪电战”中，该地区的许多建筑遭到损坏或彻底摧毁，这场轰炸导致4万多平民丧生。许多幸存的大房子被卖给了房东，他们将其分割成多户住宅，租客们租下一间房或是一整层。诺丁山拉德布鲁克格罗夫社区的灵顿街10号就是这样一处住所。
It was the 10th house in a row of narrow, matching three-story brick residences situated at the end of a cul-de-sac that adjoined a busy thoroughfare named St. Mark's Road. All of the houses had been built during the 1870s and by the late 1940s they had fallen into neglect and disrepair. As they were home to so many residents, the street had a bustling atmosphere, with local children often gathering outside to play during the summer months. The landlord for number 10 lived elsewhere. They had split the house into three flats that each occupied an entire story of the building. It was poorly maintained and had no phone or indoor bathroom facilities.
它是死胡同尽头一排狭窄、相连且高三层的砖砌住宅中的第十栋，这条死胡同与一条名为圣马克路的繁华干道相连。所有的房子都建于19世纪70年代，到20世纪40年代末，它们已经年久失修、破败不堪。由于居住着大量居民，这条街充满了喧闹的氛围，当地的儿童经常在夏日聚在外面玩耍。10号的房东住在别处。他们将房子分成了三套公寓，每套公寓占据建筑的一整层。这里维护不善，没有电话或室内卫浴设施。
Instead, residents had to use bedpans or a lavatory in the backyard, which adjoined a small communal wash house. In March 1948, the property's ground and middle-floor flats were leased to long-term tenants, but the top floor remained available to rent. Newlyweds, Timothy and Beryl Evans had been living with Timothy's parents and sisters just around the corner on St. Mark's Road. Their living quarters were small and crowded. When Beryl discovered she was pregnant, she and Timothy decided it was time to find a place of their own. They were informed of a house nearby that had a sign in its top-floor window reading, Flat to Let. Its affordability, coupled with its convenient location near their extended family,
相反，居民们不得不使用便盆或后院的厕所，后院连着一个小型的公共洗衣房。1948年3月，这处房产的一楼和二楼公寓被租给了长期租客，但顶楼仍然空置待租。新婚夫妇蒂莫西和贝瑞尔·埃文斯曾与蒂莫西的父母和姐妹们住在圣马克路拐角处。他们的住所狭窄而拥挤。当贝瑞尔发现自己怀孕时，她和蒂莫西决定是时候找一个属于他们自己的地方了。他们听说附近有一栋房子，顶楼的窗户上挂着一块牌子，上面写着“公寓出租”。这里价格实惠，加上地理位置便利，靠近他们的大家庭，
compelled the Evans' to submit an application, despite the property's less than desirable features. Their submission was approved, and on Monday, March 29, 1948, the young couple moved into 10 Rillington Place. Beryl, Susanna Thorley Beryl Susanna Thorley was born on September 19, 1929, in the south-east London area of Lewisham. She was the oldest of four children, with two younger brothers and a sister. During the Second World War, the Thorleys moved to the west London neighbourhood of Kensington. When Beryl's mother died in 1947, her father relocated to the Seaside Resort of Brighton, roughly 53 miles south of the capital. Beryl remained in London, where she worked as a telephone switchboard operator at Groverner House Hotel on Park Lane, a hotel in the upmarket district of Mayfair.
促使埃文斯夫妇提交了申请，尽管这栋房子的条件实在算不上理想。他们的申请获批，1948年3月29日星期一，这对年轻夫妇搬进了灵顿街10号。贝瑞尔，苏珊娜·索利，贝瑞尔·苏珊娜·索利于1929年9月19日出生于伦敦东南部的刘易舍姆。她是四个孩子中的老大，有两个弟弟和一个妹妹。二战期间，索利一家搬到了伦敦西部的肯辛顿社区。1947年贝瑞尔的母亲去世后，她的父亲搬到了位于首都以南约53英里海滨度假胜地布赖顿。贝瑞尔留在了伦敦，在梅菲尔高档区帕克巷的格罗夫纳豪房酒店担任电话总机接线员。
One of her colleagues was dating a young man, who in turn offered to set Beryl up on a blind date with his friend. Timothy John Evans was born on November 20, 1924, in the Welsh mining town of Murther Tidville, located in the country's south. His father, who worked locally as a coal haulier, abandoned the family seven months before Timothy was born. As a result, Timothy and his older sister Eileen were raised by their mother, Thomasina. In 1929, she remarried another coal worker named Penry Probert. Later that year, the newlyweds had a daughter, Mary. Timothy Evans' childhood was marred by a number of developmental delays. He struggled to walk and speak, though eventually learned how to do both. At age eight, Timothy cut a toe on his right foot on some glass by a river. The wound was bandaged to using a dirty cloth, which led to him developing tubercular veruca, a rash of small, red, papula nodules related to the infectious disease tuberculosis.
她的一位同事当时正在和一个年轻男子交往，后者随后主动提出安排贝瑞尔和他的朋友进行一次盲相亲。蒂莫西·约翰·埃文斯于1924年11月20日出生于该国南部的威尔士采矿小镇迈瑟蒂德菲尔。他的父亲在当地做煤炭运输工，在蒂莫西出生前七个月抛弃了这个家庭。因此，蒂莫西和他的姐姐艾琳由母亲托马西娜抚养长大。1929年，她改嫁给另一个名叫佩里·普罗伯特的煤炭工人。同年晚些时候，这对新婚夫妇生了一个女儿玛丽。蒂莫西·埃文斯的童年伴随着多重发育迟缓。他学走路和说话都很艰难，不过最终还是学会了这两样。八岁时，蒂莫西右脚脚趾在河边被玻璃割伤。伤口用一块脏布包扎，导致他患上了结核性疣，这是一种与传染病结核病相关的、由小型红色丘疹组成的皮疹。
The injury never healed properly, and Timothy was often in hospital receiving treatments. He missed out on much of his schooling, causing his literacy to suffer to the extent that he could barely write and could only read simple texts such as comic books. In 1935, when Timothy was ten years old, the Welsh coalfields were experiencing a depression, so his stepfather relocated to London in search of work. The rest of the family joined him six weeks later, settling in the cities in the West. Timothy continued to miss school due to his ill health. In 1939, he was sent to a clinic in Hampshire that specialized in treating children with tuberculosis and stayed for an entire year. Though the physicians there couldn't entirely fix Timothy's foot injury, they managed to treat it effectively enough that it never bothered him significantly again, though he was left with a permanent limp. By the time he reached adulthood, Timothy stood at five foot five inches tall and had a slight frame. Described as cocky and cheerful, he had dark eyes and dark hair, which he slicked back across his head.
这个伤口从未完全愈合，蒂莫西经常在医院接受治疗。他错过了大部分学业，导致识字能力严重受损，几乎不会写字，只能阅读漫画书等简单的文本。1935年，蒂莫西十岁时，威尔士煤田遭遇萧条，他的继父为了谋生搬到了伦敦。六个月后，其余家人也加入了他的行列，定居在西部的城市。由于身体健康状况不佳，蒂莫西继续缺课。1939年，他被送往汉普郡的一家诊所，该诊所专门治疗患有结核病的儿童，并在那里待了一整年。尽管那里的医生无法完全治愈蒂莫西的脚伤，但他们成功地进行了治疗，使其再也没有严重困扰过他，不过他留下了一个永久的跛足。到成年时，蒂莫西身高五英尺五英寸，身材瘦弱。他被形容为自负而开朗，有着黑色的眼睛和黑色的头发，头发向后梳理贴在头皮上。
His leg impairment excused him from military service during World War II, and he remained in London with his family as the city endured the blitz. Although his limited education hindered his work prospects, he managed to secure a job as a car cleaner. Amongst friends and family, Timothy was renowned for exaggerating and telling tall tales. He'd developed the habit as a form of entertainment when he was bedridden as a child. He claimed that his father was an Italian count and that he had a brother who owned an enormous fleet of cars. Though he had a Welsh accent, he would sometimes feign a cockney manner of speaking to fit in with his English friends. Thomasina attributed her son's fibbing to his lack of self-confidence. If caught out in a lie, Timothy would become ashamed and would plead with his mother not to tell his older sister Eileen, whom he adored. In January 1947, shortly after Timothy's 22nd birthday, a friend offered to set him up on a date with a girl named Beryl Thorley.
由于腿部残疾，他在二战期间免于服兵役，并随着城市经受闪电战而与家人一起留在伦敦。尽管有限的教育限制了他的就业前景，但他还是找到了一份汽车清洗工的工作。在亲友中，蒂莫西以夸大其词和爱说大话而闻名。他在童年卧病在床时养成了这种作为消遣的习惯。他声称自己的父亲是一位意大利伯爵，自己还有一个拥有庞大车队的兄弟。尽管他带有威尔士口音，但他有时会假装伦敦腔，以融入他的英国朋友。托马西娜将儿子的谎言归咎于他缺乏自信。如果谎言被戳穿，蒂莫西会感到羞耻，并恳求母亲不要告诉他所崇拜的姐姐艾琳。1947年1月，在蒂莫西22岁生日后不久，一个朋友提出安排他和一个叫贝瑞尔·索利的女孩约会。
Timothy was drawn to the petite, dark-haired Beryl, and the pair hit it off instantly. They met several more times to attend local dances and to go to the cinema. Within weeks of their first date, they became engaged. On September 20, one day after Beryl's 18th birthday, they married at Kensington Registry Office. Six months later, the couple moved into 10 Rillington Place in preparation of their growing family. Their flat consisted of a single bedroom with a joint living and kitchen space. Despite the cramped quarters and lack of modern amenities, they liked their new home and decided to stay put even when told of a ground floor flat available elsewhere that had its own garden and lavatory. Number 10 Rillington Place had several communal areas, including the hallway, staircase, and outside rear yard, so the evansers often saw their neighbours throughout the day.
蒂莫西被娇小、黑发的贝瑞尔所吸引，两人一拍即合。他们多次见面参加当地的舞会和去看电影。在第一次约会几周后，他们订婚了。9月20日，即贝瑞尔18岁生日的第二天，他们在肯辛顿登记处结婚。六个月后，为了迎接家庭新成员的到来，这对夫妇搬进了灵顿街10号。他们的公寓包括一间卧室以及连体的起居和厨房空间。尽管空间狭窄且缺乏现代设施，但他们还是喜欢这个新家，甚至在得知别处有一套带花园和厕所的一楼公寓空置时，也决定留在这里不搬走。灵顿街10号有几个公共区域，包括走廊、楼梯和外部后院，因此埃文斯夫妇整天都能看到邻居。
The ground floor flat was home to another married couple, while the middle residence was occupied by an elderly man. Later that year, Timothy commenced a new job as a delivery driver for a food wholesaler. He managed to drive a van all over London, despite having difficulty reading signs and maps. On Sunday, October 10, 1948, Timothy and Beryl welcomed their firstborn, a girl they named Geraldine. Beryl was an affectionate mother, while Timothy spent hours playing with his daughter. He would bring her home small gifts that he collected throughout his delivery shifts. On Wednesday evenings, Thomasina would babysit her grandchild so that the new parents could go to the cinema together. Yet, their relationship grew increasingly fraught and difficult.
一楼的公寓住着另一对夫妇，而中间的住所则由一位老汉居住。同年晚些时候，蒂莫西开始了一份新工作，担任一家食品批发商的送货司机。尽管阅读路标和地图有困难，他还是设法开着货车跑遍了整个伦敦。1948年10月10日星期日，蒂莫西和贝瑞尔迎来了他们的长女，他们给她取名叫杰拉丁。贝瑞尔是一位慈爱的母亲，而蒂莫西则花好几个小时陪女儿玩耍。他会把在送货途中收集的小礼物带回家给女儿。星期三晚上，托马西娜会帮他们照看孙女，这样这对新手父母就可以一起去看电影了。然而，他们的关系却变得越来越紧张和艰难。
Money was scarce. They struggled to afford rent and make repayments on their furniture. Timothy felt his wife did not know how to cook, clean, or manage a household budget. Beryl was frustrated at the amount of time and money her husband spent drinking at local pubs. He also had a quick temper that was exacerbated by alcohol. Their neighbours overheard their loud arguments, which sometimes became physical. By July 1949, Beryl had returned to work part-time to support her family. She struck up a mild flirtation with a colleague and once teased Timothy about it when he paid her a visit. He slapped her, and the pair caused a scene that resulted in Beryl losing her job.
资金匮乏。他们艰难地支付房租和家具的分期付款。蒂莫西觉得他的妻子既不会做饭、打扫卫生，也不会管理家庭预算。贝瑞尔则对丈夫花时间和金钱在当地酒吧喝酒感到沮丧。他还有暴躁的脾气，酒精更是加剧了这一倾向。邻居们无意中听到他们大声争吵，有时甚至演变成肢体冲突。到1949年7月，贝瑞尔为了补贴家用，已经恢复了兼职工作。她与一位同事产生了轻微的暧昧关系，当蒂莫西去看望她时，她还以此取笑蒂莫西。他打了她一巴掌，两人大闹了一场，结果贝瑞尔失去了工作。
On another occasion, Beryl threw a jar of baby cream at her husband, causing a gash that required stitches. Beryl's father concluded that his daughter was unhappily married, and her relationship with Timothy was not, quote, a genuine friendship. Other relatives and acquaintances were of the opposite opinion, believing the couple were happy and in love. Timothy's younger sister, Mary, attributed their marital issues to struggling to make ends meet in post-war London. A young girl who babysat Geraldine described them as a lovely couple, very fond of each other. They did quarrel a bit, but never badly, and never for long. On the evening of August 28, 1949, a police officer was called to 10 Rillington Place following reports of a loud fight.
在另一次争吵中，贝瑞尔向丈夫扔了一罐婴儿面霜，导致他的一道伤口需要缝针。贝瑞尔的父亲断定女儿的婚姻并不幸福，她与蒂莫西的关系“算不上真正的友谊”。其他亲戚和熟人则持相反意见，认为这对夫妇很幸福且相爱。蒂莫西的妹妹玛丽将他们的婚姻问题归咎于战后伦敦勉强维生的挣扎。一个照顾过杰拉丁的小女孩形容他们是一对恩爱的夫妇，彼此非常喜欢。他们确实会吵点小架，但从不严重，也从不持久。1949年8月28日晚上，一名警察接到关于大声争吵的报警后，被召至灵顿街10号。
In the top floor flat, they found Timothy, Beryl, Tomasina, and a teenage girl in the midst of an argument. The girl, 17-year-old Lucy Endicott, was a friend of Beryl's who was temporarily staying with the Evans''. Beryl had slapped Lucy after accusing her of sleeping with her husband the previous night. Tomasina was demanding Lucy leave as her presence was causing problems in her son's marriage. Lucy denied the allegations. She claimed to have witnessed Timothy beat Beryl and threatened to throw her out of a window. The feud ended with Lucy and Timothy leaving the flat. They stayed together for two nights until Lucy tired of his company and went home to her mother.
在顶楼公寓里，他们发现蒂莫西、贝瑞尔、托马西娜和一个十几岁的女孩正处于争吵之中。这个名叫露西·恩迪科特的17岁女孩是贝瑞尔的朋友，当时暂时借住在埃文斯夫妇家。贝瑞尔扇了露西耳光，指控她前一晚和自己的丈夫睡过觉。托马西娜要求露西离开，因为她的存在给她儿子的婚姻造成了问题。露西否认了这些指控。她声称目睹了蒂莫西殴打贝瑞尔，并威胁要把她扔出窗外。这场争端以露西和蒂莫西离开公寓告终。他们在一起待了两天，直到露西厌倦了他的陪伴，回家找她的母亲去了。
Timothy returned to Beryl, who accepted him back. At around 7am on Tuesday, November 15, 1949, Cornelius Lynch was in the midst of preparing for work when he heard a knock on the front door. He was surprised to greet his 24-year-old nephew, Timothy Evans, the son of his sister, Tomasina. Timothy was far from home. Although he was born and raised in Southern Wales, he currently lived in London, 164 miles from Cornelius's house in the Welsh village of Murthervale. Timothy informed his uncle that he had been travelling with his boss searching for areas to expand his food wholesaler business. Their car broke down in the city of Cardiff, about half an hour's drive south, leaving them stranded for a few days at least. Cornelius and his wife, Violet, were happy to let their nephew stay with them for as long as he needed.
蒂莫西回到了贝瑞尔身边，而她接纳了他。1949年11月15日星期二早上7点左右，科尼利厄斯·林奇正在准备上班，突然听到前门传来敲门声。他惊讶地迎来了自己24岁的侄子蒂莫西·埃文斯，也就是他妹妹托马西娜的儿子。蒂莫西离家很远。尽管他在南威尔士出生长大，但他目前住在伦敦，距离科尼利厄斯在威尔士村庄迈瑟维尔的家有164英里远。蒂莫西告诉他的叔叔，他一直在和老板一起旅行，寻找扩大其食品批发业务的区域。他们的车在卡迪夫市抛锚了，卡迪夫在南面大约半小时车程的地方，这让他们至少滞留了几天。科尼利厄斯和他的妻子维奥莱特很高兴让侄子在他们家住多久都行。
Timothy spent the following days going for walks in the nearby hills, reading comics by the fire and accompanying his aunt on shopping errands. A week-long absence from home would go unnoticed, as Beryl was holidaying at her widowed father's place in Brighton and had taken one-year-old Geraldine with her. A framed picture of the infant was displayed in the Lynch's house, and Timothy was often caught talking to it. On one occasion, he turned to his aunt, Violet, and told her, Just wait till you see her, Auntie Violet. She's a smasher. While at a pub with his nephew one day, Cornelius noticed Timothy holding what appeared to be a woman's wedding ring. When asked if it was Beryl's, Timothy said no, he'd just found it somewhere. He also gifted an old friend's wife a necklace, though didn't reveal where it had come from.
接下来的几天里，蒂莫西在附近的山丘上散步，在火炉旁读漫画书，并陪着姑姑去买杂货。由于贝瑞尔当时正在布赖顿她丧偶的父亲家度假，并且带上了一岁的杰拉丁，因此他离家一周并未引起注意。林奇家中摆放着婴儿的框装照片，蒂莫西经常被发现对着照片自言自语。有一次，他转身对姑姑维奥莱特说：“维奥莱特姑妈，等您见到她就知道了。她是个标致的小姑娘。”一天，科尼利厄斯和侄子在酒吧时，注意到蒂莫西手里拿着一件看起来像是女性结婚戒指的东西。当被问及这是不是贝瑞尔的时，蒂莫西说不是，他只是在什么地方捡到的。他还送给一个老朋友的妻子一条项链，但没有透露它是从哪里来的。
On his fifth day in Murthervale, Timothy celebrated his 25th birthday. He left the following day of Monday, November 21, telling the Lynch's he needed to meet his boss in Cardiff to collect some pay and expenses. Three days later, Timothy reappeared. He admitted to his aunt and uncle that he never went to Cardiff, he had actually been back to London. When asked if he had seen his wife and daughter during his brief trip home, Timothy replied that he had. He revealed that Beryl had walked out on him and baby Geraldine. During his journey back to Murthervale, he dropped his daughter off with some acquaintances in the city of Newport, just outside of Cardiff. The Lynch's were suspicious of their nephew's odd behavior and confusing explanations and were not inclined to believe that Beryl had abandoned him and her baby.
在迈瑟维尔的第五天，蒂莫西庆祝了他的25岁生日。他在第二天11月21日星期一离开，告诉林奇一家他需要去卡迪夫见老板领取一些薪水和差旅费。三天后，蒂莫西重新出现。他向叔叔婶婶承认，他根本没去卡迪夫，实际上是回过伦敦。当被问及他在短暂的回家之行中是否见过妻子和女儿时，蒂莫西回答说见了。他透露贝瑞尔抛弃了他和婴儿杰拉丁。在返回迈瑟维尔的旅途中，他把女儿留在了卡迪夫郊外纽波特市的一些熟人那里。林奇夫妇对侄子古怪的行为和混乱的解释感到怀疑，并不倾向于相信贝瑞尔抛弃了他和孩子。
One night, Cornelius asked Timothy to again confirm what had happened. He changed his story, this time saying Beryl was pregnant by another man so he had left her and would never see her again. Meanwhile, Timothy's mother and sisters hadn't heard from him in more than a fortnight. On Sunday, November 27, Timothy's sister Eileen visited 10 Rillington Place only to find the Evans' top story flat quiet. She inquired with the neighbors and spoke to the occupants of the ground floor flat, a middle-aged couple named John and Ethel Christie. Ethel reported that Beryl had left the property with Geraldine almost three weeks earlier on Tuesday, November 8. She was certain of it as she helped Beryl carry her bags. Ethel's husband to John told Eileen, they've had a row, best to leave young couples alone.
一天晚上，科尼利厄斯要求蒂莫西再次确认发生了什么。他改变了说法，这次说贝瑞尔怀上了别人的孩子，所以他离开了她，再也不会见到她了。与此同时，蒂莫西的母亲和姐妹们已经有半个多月没听到他的消息了。11月27日星期日，蒂莫西的姐姐艾琳拜访了灵顿街10号，却发现埃文斯夫妇的顶层公寓一片安静。她向邻居打听，并与一楼公寓的住户——一对名叫约翰和埃瑟尔·克里斯特的中年夫妇交谈了。埃瑟尔报告说，贝瑞尔大约在三周前的11月8日星期二带着杰拉丁离开了这里。她对此确信不疑，因为她曾帮贝瑞尔拎过包。埃瑟尔的丈夫约翰对艾琳说：“他们吵了一架，最好别管年轻夫妇的事。”
The following day, Timothy's other sister Mary arrived at Rillington Place to carry out her own investigations. She also spoke with the Christie's and couldn't understand why Beryl hadn't written as she must have known they would worry if they didn't hear from her. John Christie revealed that Timothy had sold all the couple's furniture as though he had no intention to return. It appeared to have been in response to his mother, who was interfering with the couple's lives too much. John stated that Beryl left without saying goodbye, though his wife claimed otherwise, explaining Beryl bid her farewell and stated she would write. Mary planned to contact the police if she didn't hear from her brother or Beryl by the end of the week. John Christie advised her against it, as Timothy would not thank her if she involved the authorities in his personal matters. When Tomasina last spoke with her son, he claimed that Beryl and Geraldine were holidaying in Brighton.
第二天，蒂莫西的另一个妹妹玛丽来到灵顿街进行她自己的调查。她也和克里斯特夫妇交谈过，无法理解为什么贝瑞尔没有写信，因为她一定知道如果听不到她的消息，他们会担心的。约翰·克里斯特透露，蒂莫西把这对夫妇的所有家具都卖了，好像他根本不打算回来一样。这似乎是对他母亲干涉这对夫妇生活太多的反应。约翰声称贝瑞尔不告而别，不过他的妻子却说并非如此，解释说贝瑞尔向她道了别，并表示会写信。玛丽计划如果到周末还没有收到哥哥或贝瑞尔的消息就报警。约翰·克里斯特劝她不要这么做，因为如果她把当局牵扯进蒂莫西的私事中，蒂莫西是不会感谢她的。托马西娜最后一次和儿子通话时，儿子声称贝瑞尔和杰拉丁正在布赖顿度假。
Yet, it had been almost a month since the otherwise communicative Beryl contacted her in-laws. Tomasina sent a telegram to Beryl's father in Brighton, as she had purchased a dress for Geraldine as a Christmas gift and wanted to confirm Beryl would still be there before sending it. In his reply, Beryl's father revealed that his daughter hadn't been staying with him. A short time later, Tomasina received a letter from her sister-in-law, Violet Lynch, informing her that Timothy had spent the previous two weeks at her home in Murthervale. A number of individuals told Tomasina that her son owed them money, leading her to suspect he had run away from his debts. Furious that Timothy was lying and had seemingly abandoned his responsibilities, Tomasina wrote back to Violet. She panned. There is some mystery about him. You can tell him from me. I never want to see him again as long as I live. He packed up a good job here. He is like his father. No good to himself or anybody else. Violet Lynch received Tomasina's letter the morning of Wednesday, November 30. She read it to Timothy at the breakfast table before accusing him of lying.
然而，原本很健谈的贝瑞尔已经快一个月没有联系她的公公婆婆了。托马西娜给贝瑞尔在布赖顿的父亲发了一封电报，因为她为杰拉丁买了一件衣服作为圣诞礼物，想在寄出之前确认贝瑞尔是否还在那里。在回信中，贝瑞尔的父亲透露他的女儿一直没有和他住在一起。不久后，托马西娜收到小姑子维奥莱特·林奇的一封信，信中告知蒂莫西在迈瑟维尔她的家度过了过去的两个星期。许多人告诉托马西娜她的儿子欠了他们钱，这导致她怀疑他是为了躲债而逃跑了。托马西娜对蒂莫西说谎且似乎抛弃了责任感到愤怒，她回信给维奥莱特。她写道：“他身上有些蹊跷。你可以替我转告他。只要我活着，就再也不想见到他了。他在这里辞掉了一份好工作。他跟他父亲一样，对自己和任何人都没用。”维奥莱特·林奇于11月30日星期三早晨收到了托马西娜的信。她在餐桌上读给蒂莫西听，然后指责他说谎。
He maintained his story that Beryl and Geraldine were in Brighton. He also denied selling their furniture. He appeared anxious and didn't finish eating his meal. At 3.10 that afternoon, he walked into Murthervale's police station. Timothy told the officer on duty, Detective Constable Gwynfren Evans, I would like to have a chat with you alone. He was taken into the station's charge office, where he announced, I want to give myself up. I have disposed of my wife. When asked what he meant, Timothy elaborated. I put her down the drain. The detective queried whether Timothy knew what he was admitting to. He answered, Yes, I know what I'm saying. I can't sleep and want to get it off my chest. He was cautioned and asked if he wanted to make a written statement. As he couldn't read or write, Timothy suggested he talk about it while officers dictated. He was then transferred five miles north to the criminal investigation department in his hometown of Murther Tidville.
他坚持他先前的说法，坚称贝瑞尔和杰拉丁在布赖顿。他还否认卖掉他们的家具。他显得很焦虑，没有吃完饭。那天下午3点10分，他走进了迈瑟维尔的警察局。蒂莫西对值班警官、侦探警员格温弗伦·埃文斯说：“我想单独和您聊聊。”他被带到警察局的问询室，在那里他宣布：“我要自首。我处理掉了我的妻子。”当被问及这是什么意思时，蒂莫西详细解释道：“我把她顺着下水道扔下去了。”侦探询问蒂莫西是否知道自己在承认什么。他回答说：“是的，我知道我在说什么。我睡不着觉，想卸下心头大石。”他受到了警告，并被问及是否想做出一份书面记录。由于不会读写，蒂莫西建议他讲述，由警官口述记录。随后，他被向北转移了五英里，带到了他家乡迈瑟蒂德菲尔的刑事调查部。
Once there, Timothy gave an official statement to Detective Constable Gwynfren Evans and another officer, Detective Sergeant Glindor Goff. He started with the discovery months earlier that Beryl was pregnant with their second child. The news distressed 19-year-old Beryl, who was already struggling to make ends meet with one child. She had also started a new job at a news agency and would have to quit if she had another baby. She wanted to terminate the pregnancy, but abortions were illegal in the United Kingdom at the time. Timothy didn't share his wife's concern, telling her, If you are having a baby, well, you've had one. Another one won't make any difference. Beryl said about trying to abort the pregnancy herself. Timothy warned that she would only end up making herself unwell, but Beryl was adamant.
到了那里后，蒂莫西向侦探警员格温弗伦·埃文斯和另一名警官、侦探中士格林多·戈夫做出了正式陈述。他从几个月前发现贝瑞尔怀上他们的第二个孩子开始讲起。这个消息让19岁的贝瑞尔感到苦恼，她带着一个孩子就已经很难维持生计了。她还在一家新闻社找到了一份新工作，如果再生一个孩子就不得不辞职。她想终止妊娠，但在当时的英国，堕胎是非法的。蒂莫西并不认同妻子的担忧，对她说：“如果你要生孩子，好吧，你已经生过一个了。再多一个也没什么区别。”贝瑞尔说要自己设法打胎。蒂莫西警告说，她只会把自己的身体搞垮，但贝瑞尔态度坚决。
Timothy approached his mother to see whether she knew of anything that could induce a miscarriage. As a practicing Catholic, Tomasina was firmly against the idea. Beryl also discussed the matter with Timothy's sisters, her brother, a friend, and her neighbors, John and Dethyl Christie. At the advice of those she spoke to, she obtained some over-the-counter pills and a syringe to inject glycerine and carboleic soap into her body, but her attempts failed. As time went on, the combination of her unhappy marriage, unwanted pregnancy, and other home remedies caused Beryl to become increasingly ill and emotionally distraught. She confided to her neighbor, Ethyl Christie, that she wanted to have an illegal abortion performed, but couldn't afford one. Then, in early November, Beryl's overall well-being appeared to improve. On Friday, November 4, her brother, Basil, noted that she seemed to be in good spirits, with upcoming plans to go on a holiday with baby Geraldine.
蒂莫西去找他的母亲，看她是否知道有什么东西可以引发流产。作为一名虔诚的天主教徒，托马西娜坚决反对这个想法。贝瑞尔还与蒂莫西的姐姐们、她的弟弟、一个朋友以及邻居约翰和黛瑟尔·克里斯特讨论了此事。在她交谈过的人的建议下，她买了一些非处方药，并用注射器将甘油和石炭酸皂注入体内，但她的尝试都失败了。随着时间的推移，不幸的婚姻、意外怀孕以及其他家庭偏方交织在一起，导致贝瑞尔的病情日益恶化，情绪崩溃。她向邻居埃瑟尔·克里斯特吐露，她想进行一次非法流产，但负担不起费用。接着，在11月初，贝瑞尔的整体健康状况似乎有所改善。11月4日星期金，她的弟弟巴西尔指出，她看起来精神不错，并有带着婴儿杰拉丁去度假的计划。
Yet, her husband told a different story. On Sunday, November 6, after a month of trying and failing to induce a miscarriage, Beryl told Timothy that if she couldn't have an abortion, then she would take her own life, as well as Geraldine's. The following morning, Timothy visited a cafe for breakfast. A man sitting nearby engaged him in conversation, asking, You were looking pretty worried. Is there anything on your mind? Timothy shared his troubles with the stranger, who in turn gave him a bottle wrapped in brown paper, stating, Tell your wife to take it first thing in the morning before she has any tea, then to lay down on the bed for a couple of hours, and that should do the job. That night, Beryl went to fetch a cigarette from her husband's coat pocket and discovered the bottle.
然而，她丈夫的说法却截然不同。11月6日星期日，在尝试流产一个月未果后，贝瑞尔告诉蒂莫西，如果她不能流产，她就会结束自己以及杰拉丁的生命。第二天早上，蒂莫西去一家咖啡馆吃早餐。一个坐在附近的人与他搭话，问道：“你看起来很发愁。有什么心事吗？”蒂莫西向这个陌生人倾诉了他的烦恼，陌生人随后递给他一个用棕色纸包裹的瓶子，并说道：“让你妻子一大早喝下它，在喝任何茶之前，然后躺在床上几个小时，这就行了。”那天晚上，贝瑞尔去丈夫的外套口袋里拿香烟时发现了这个瓶子。
Timothy spoke of his encounter with the stranger at the cafe, but cautioned her not to consume the bottle's contents. He went to work the next day of Tuesday, November 8. Upon returning home in the evening, he noticed the flat was in darkness. Inside, he found Beryl in bed, deceased. Between 1 and 2 am, he dragged Beryl's body downstairs, out the front door, and lowered her head first into a storm drain. He then smoked a cigarette by the living room fire. Timothy claimed he didn't go to work the next day, and instead resigned, telling his employer that he had received a better offer. He visited his mother to tell her Beryl and Geraldine had gone to Brighton.
蒂莫西谈到了他在咖啡馆与陌生人的偶遇，但警告她不要喝下瓶子里的东西。第二天11月8日星期二，他去上班了。傍晚回家时，他注意到公寓里一片漆黑。进屋后，他发现贝瑞尔躺在床上，已经去世了。在凌晨1点到2点之间，他把贝瑞尔的身体拖下楼，带到前门外，然后头朝下将她放进了一个暴雨排水沟里。随后他在起居室的炉火旁抽了一根烟。蒂莫西声称他第二天没有去上班，而是辞职了，告诉雇主他接到了更好的工作邀请。他去探望母亲，告诉她贝瑞尔和杰拉丁去了布赖顿。
He then arranged to have a second-hand furniture dealer purchase all of his furniture for £40. The dealer couldn't collect the items until Monday, November 14, so Timothy remained in London for the next five days. Afterwards, he caught a train to Wales to visit his aunt and uncle in Murthervale. He told the officers that he had arranged for someone to look after baby Geraldine before departing. Timothy concluded his statement at 5.10 pm, at which point it was read back to him and he signed it. Three officers were dispatched to 10 Rillington Place, where they spotted a storm drain in the street out front, as Timothy described. Even with their combined strength, they were unable to lift its heavy cover. Their efforts drew the attention of ground floor resident John Christie, who emerged from his flat and re-affirmed that Beryl and Geraldine had left some time ago.
然后，他安排一个二手家具商以40英镑的价格买下他所有的家具。家具商直到11月14日星期一才能来收货，因此蒂莫西在伦敦逗留了接下来的五天。之后，他坐火车去威尔士看望他在迈瑟维尔的叔叔婶婶。他告诉警官们，他在离开前已经安排好让人照顾婴儿杰拉丁。蒂莫西于下午5点10分结束了他的陈述，随后陈述被读给他听，他并在上面签了字。三名警官被派往灵顿街10号，正如蒂莫西所描述的那样，他们在前面的街道上发现了一个暴雨排水沟。尽管他们合力，也无法掀开沉重的井盖。他们的努力吸引了一楼居民约翰·克里斯特的注意，他从公寓里走出来，再次坚称贝瑞尔和杰拉丁在一段时间前就已经离开了。
Through the use of levers, the officers were finally able to lift the storm drain lid. They peered inside, only to find it empty. At approximately 9 pm, Detective Constable Gwynfren Evans returned to where Timothy Evans was being held and told him, the drain which you say you put your wife's body down has been examined and there is nothing there. He replied, well, I put it there. When asked who helped him lift the cover, Timothy stated that he had done so entirely by himself. Given its weight, the detective was skeptical and remarked, I don't think that your wife's body has ever been in the drain. Timothy responded, no, I said that to protect a man named Christie.
在杠杆的帮助下，警官们终于掀开了雨水沟的盖子。他们探头往里看，却发现里面空无一人。大约晚上9点，侦探警员格温弗伦·埃文斯回到关押蒂莫西·埃文斯的地点，对他说：“你所说放置你妻子尸体的排水沟已经检查过了，里面什么都没有。”他回答说：“好吧，我把它放在那儿了。”当被问及是谁帮他掀开井盖时，蒂莫西声称完全是他自己一个人干的。考虑到井盖的重量，侦探表示怀疑并评论道：“我认为你妻子的尸体根本没有在排水沟里。”蒂莫西回应说：“没有，我这么说是为了保护一个叫克里斯特的人。”
It's not true about the man in the cafe either. I'll tell you the truth now. He then proceeded to give a second statement which the officers transcribed. He admitted to lying about meeting a stranger in a cafe, but maintained the rest of his statement was essentially true. Roughly a week before Beryl had died, Timothy was approached by his downstairs neighbour, John Christie. John, who was aware of Beryl's attempts to terminate her pregnancy, remarked, I'd like to have a chat with you about your wife taking these tablets. I know what she's taking them for, she's trying to get rid of the baby.
关于咖啡馆里那个人的事也不是真的。我现在把实情告诉你。随后，他开始提供第二份供词，警官们将其记录了下来。他承认自己说谎称在咖啡馆遇到陌生人，但坚持其余的陈述基本属实。在贝瑞尔去世前大约一周，蒂莫西被楼下邻居约翰·克里斯特搭话。约翰知道贝瑞尔试图终止妊娠，便评论道：“我想和你聊聊你妻子吃这些药的事。我知道她吃这些药是为了什么，她想把孩子打掉。”
If you or your wife had come to me in the first place, I could have done it for you without any risk. John revealed that he had been studying to be a doctor prior to the outbreak of World War One and showed Timothy a medical textbook he owned. Timothy was unable to read it, but it contained diagrams and illustrations of the human anatomy. John said he could perform an abortion, but cautioned there was a one in ten chance Beryl would die. Timothy was disinterested in the offer and went upstairs to his flat. When he entered, Beryl immediately asked whether John Christie had spoken to him about performing an abortion. Timothy said he had, but told Beryl she wasn't to have anything to do with it. As she trusted John, she intended to take him up on his offer.
如果你或你妻子一开始就来找我，我本可以毫无风险地帮你们办妥。”约翰透露，他在第一次世界大战爆发前曾学过医，并向蒂莫西展示了他拥有的一本医学教科书。蒂莫西看不懂，但书里有人体解剖学的图表和插图。约翰说他可以实施堕胎，但警告说贝瑞尔有十分之一的死亡几率。蒂莫西对这个提议不感兴趣，便上楼回了自己的公寓。他一进门，贝瑞尔立刻问约翰·克里斯特有没有跟他谈过做流产手术的事。蒂莫西说谈过，但告诉贝瑞尔她绝不能跟这事扯上关系。由于她信任约翰，她打算接受他的提议。
Several days later, on Monday, November 7, Timothy arrived home from work and was told by Beryl that John Christie had made arrangements to carry out the procedure the next morning. Shortly before her husband left for work the following morning, Beryl asked him to tell John on his way out that everything was all right to proceed. She threatened to tell him herself if Timothy didn't. Timothy did as he was asked, then went to work. When he returned home that evening, John Christie was waiting for him at the bottom of the staircase. He followed Timothy upstairs and told him. It's bad news. It didn't work. Timothy entered his flat and found his wife's body on their bed covered with a quilt.
几天后的11月7日星期一，蒂莫西下班回家，贝瑞尔告诉他约翰·克里斯特已经安排好第二天早上实施手术。第二天早上丈夫出门上班前不久，贝瑞尔让他出门时顺便告诉约翰一切正常，可以进行手术。她威胁说，如果蒂莫西不去，她就自己去告诉约翰。蒂莫西照办了，然后去上班。那天傍晚他回家时，约翰·克里斯特正等在楼梯底部。他跟着蒂莫西上楼并对他说：“有个坏消息。失败了。”蒂莫西走进公寓，发现妻子的尸体盖着一条被子躺在床上。
He uncovered her, seeing that she was dressed in a black skirt, her checked blouse and a light blue jacket. There was blood around her mouth and nose and between her legs. Geraldine was nearby in her cot. Timothy picked her up, wrapped her in a blanket and took her into the kitchen where John Christie was waiting. He said Beryl had been dead since about 3 o'clock, adding that her stomach had been septic poisoned and that she would have had to go to the hospital anyway. He refused to give any details about the failed abortion procedure or what had involved. For the past month, the middle floor flat at 10 Rillington Place had been unoccupied. Its sole resident, an elderly man named Charles Kitchener, had been hospitalized to undergo an operation on his eyes.
他掀开被子，看到她穿着一条黑裙子、格子衬衫和一件浅蓝色夹克。她的嘴、鼻子周围以及双腿之间有血迹。杰拉丁在附近的婴儿床里。蒂莫西抱起她，用毯子把她裹起来，抱进厨房，约翰·克里斯特正在那里等候。他说贝瑞尔大约在3点钟左右就已经死了，并补充说她的胃已经败血症中毒，无论如何都必须去医院。他拒绝透露任何关于失败的流产手术的细节或手术涉及的内容。过去一个月里，灵顿街10号的二楼公寓一直空置。其唯一的居民、一位名叫查尔斯·基奇纳的老汉因眼部手术住院了。
John Christie took Beryl's body into the vacant flat and promised to dispose of it later down a nearby drain. Timothy remarked that it was foolish to dispose of Beryl's body, but John said it was necessary to prevent police prosecuting him for performing an illegal medical procedure. He instructed Timothy to go to work as per usual in the morning while he looked after baby Geraldine, as suspicions might arise if she was sent to her grandmother's home unexpectedly. Over the next few days, John urged Timothy to leave London as soon as possible in order to conceal the death of his wife. He recommended a local furniture dealer Timothy could sell his belongings to and said he knew a young couple in the nearby area of East Acton who would be happy to look after Geraldine. Timothy did as he was told, and while he was at work on Thursday, November 10, John had the young couple come by to collect Geraldine. Timothy told his relatives that his wife and daughter were on holiday, as instructed by John, and disposed of Beryl's clothing by tearing it up into pieces and giving them to a rag dealer. Once his personal affairs were in order and the flat was empty, he caught a train to Murthervale.
约翰·克里斯特将贝瑞尔的尸体搬进空置的公寓，并承诺稍后将其处理在附近的下水道里。蒂莫西评论说处理掉贝瑞尔的尸体很愚蠢，但约翰说这是为了防止警方以实施非法医疗程序的罪名起诉他。他指示蒂莫西早上照常去上班，而他则来照看婴儿杰拉丁，因为如果她意外地被送到祖母家可能会引起怀疑。在接下来的几天里，约翰敦促蒂莫西尽快离开伦敦，以掩盖他妻子的死讯。他推荐了一位当地的家具商，蒂莫西可以把物品卖给他，并说他认识附近伊斯特阿克敦的一对年轻夫妇，他们很乐意照看杰拉丁。蒂莫西照做了。11月10日星期四他上班时，约翰让那对年轻夫妇顺道来接走了杰拉丁. 蒂莫西按照约翰的指示，告诉亲戚他的妻子和女儿去度假了，并通过把贝瑞尔的衣服撕成碎片并送给破烂商来处理掉了它们。一旦个人事务处理妥当且公寓空无一人，他便坐火车去了迈瑟维尔。
By the time Timothy concluded giving this second statement, it was 11.50pm. He had been in police custody for almost nine hours and spent the remainder of the night in solitary confinement. Both John and Ethel Christie were questioned at length in relation to Timothy's accusations. John denied offering to perform an abortion on Beryl that had been aware she was trying to terminate an unwanted pregnancy. He advised her against it for the sake of her health. Ethel told police that Beryl mentioned going to a location near a hospital where she could pay to have an abortion carried out. The Christie's described the Evans' marriage as an unhappy one, with John explaining, quote, Beryl has told my wife and I on more than one occasion that Timothy has assaulted her and grabbed hold of her throat. She said he has a violent temper and one time would do her in. John had spent the first two weeks of November practically housebound after taking time off from the factory where he worked due to ill health. On the date of Beryl's alleged death, he was at home suffering severe back pain and inflammation of the small intestine.
到蒂莫西结束第二份供词时，已经是晚上11点50分了。他已经被警方拘留了近九个小时，并在单人牢房里度过了剩下的夜晚。约翰和埃瑟尔·克里斯特就蒂莫西的指控接受了详细的盘问。约翰否认曾主动提出为贝瑞尔做流产手术，并否认知道她曾试图终止意外怀孕。他曾为了她的健康劝阻她不要这么做。埃瑟尔告诉警方，贝瑞尔曾提过去一家医院附近的地方，在那里她可以花钱做流产手术。克里斯特夫妇将埃文斯夫妇的婚姻描述为不幸的婚姻，约翰解释说：“贝瑞尔不止一次地对我和妻子说过，蒂莫西曾攻击她并掐住她的喉咙。她说他脾气暴躁，有一次甚至扬言要干掉她。”由于身体健康原因，约翰在工厂请了假，并在11月的前两周几乎足不出户。在据称贝瑞尔死亡的那天，他正因严重的背痛和小肠发炎而在家休养。
He left his flat twice to see the doctor at 5.20pm and to visit the library with his wife. John saw Beryl for the last time that day as she left the house. At 7 o'clock that evening, Timothy returned home and spoke to the Christie's, telling them that Beryl and Geraldine had gone to the city of Bristol to visit friends and he would join them later in the week. Almost a week later on Monday, November 14, Timothy told John that he had quit his job and was moving. Before his departure, Timothy gave his neighbour two suitcases as well as Geraldine's pram and high chair, asking him to hold onto them until he found a new home for his family. He reappeared almost 10 days later on Wednesday, November 23. John said that his wife had inquired about Beryl, at which point Timothy revealed that she had left him. Police also spoke with Timothy's mother, who confirmed she hadn't seen her son, his wife, or their child in weeks.
他两次离开公寓去看医生（下午5点20分）以及和妻子去图书馆。那天约翰最后一次见到贝瑞尔是她离开家的时候。当天晚上7点，蒂莫西回到家，与克里斯特夫妇交谈，告诉他们贝瑞尔和杰拉丁去了布里斯托尔市看望朋友，他将在本周晚些时候去和他们会合。将近一周后的11月14日星期日，蒂莫西告诉约翰他已经辞职并准备搬家。在离开前，蒂莫西把两个手提箱以及杰拉丁的婴儿车和高脚椅交给了邻居，请他帮忙保管，直到他为家人找到新家。大约10天后的11月23日星期三，他又出现了。约翰说他的妻子曾打听过贝瑞尔的情况，这时蒂莫西透露她已经抛弃了他。警方还与蒂莫西的母亲进行了交谈，母亲证实她已经几周没见过儿子、儿媳或他们的孩子了。
They passed on a message from Timothy, asking her to contact John Christie to confirm the address of the young couple who had Geraldine. His message didn't make sense to Thomasina, who replied, I know my son has a very vivid imagination and is a terrible liar. Timothy's personal belongings were retrieved from the Murthervale home of Cornelius and Violet Lynch, including the letter his mother sent days earlier, conveying her frustrations that he had abandoned his family. Afterwards, Detective Constable Gwynfren Evans spoke with Timothy Evans again, who feigned ignorance over the letter penned by his mother. He was asked when he last saw Beryl's body and whether he had helped John Christie move it to Charles Kitchener's middle floor flat. Here, Timothy changed his story yet again. He claimed he had heard his 50-year-old neighbour huffing and puffing as he struggled to drag his wife's body downstairs.
他们转达了蒂莫西的信息，要求她联系约翰·克里斯特以确认收留杰拉丁的那对年轻夫妇的地址。这个消息让托马西娜感到莫名其妙，她回信道：“我知道我的儿子有着非常丰富的想象力，是个大话精。”蒂莫西的个人物品是从科尼利厄斯和维奥莱特·林奇在迈瑟维尔的家中取回的，其中包括他母亲几天前寄出的信，信中表达了对他抛弃家庭的愤怒。随后，侦探警员格温弗伦·埃文斯再次与蒂莫西·埃文斯交谈，蒂莫西对母亲写的那封信假装一无所知。他被问及最后一次看到贝瑞尔的尸体是什么时候，以及他是否曾帮约翰·克里斯特将其转移到查尔斯·基奇纳的二楼公寓。在这里，蒂莫西再次改变了他的说法。他声称自己听到年过半百的邻居在吃力地把妻子的尸体往下拖时气喘吁吁。
He had then assisted by carrying her legs while John lifted her torso. Quote, That's the truth, and that's the last time I saw her body. When asked if he had returned to London after fleeing to Murthervale, Timothy responded, Oh yes, I forgot about that. He claimed to have returned to inquire about Geraldine's welfare, but John Christie had told him he couldn't visit his daughter for another two or three weeks as she was still settling in to her new home. Detective Evans expressed his disbelief at Timothy's story, prompting the response, I may have made a few mistakes, but as far as Christie is concerned, I have said the truth. Meanwhile, a search of 10 Rillington Place was underway.
然后他帮着抬她的腿，约翰则抬她的躯干。“千真万确，那是我最后一次见到她的尸体。”当被问及逃往迈瑟维尔后是否曾返回伦敦时，蒂莫西回答说：“哦，对了，我把这事给忘了。”他声称自己回来是为了打听杰拉丁的近况，但约翰·克里斯特告诉他，由于孩子还在适应新家，他还要再等两三周才能去看望女儿。埃文斯侦探对蒂莫西的说法表示难以置信，这引来了这样的回应：“我可能犯了一些错误，但就克里斯特而言，我说的都是实话。”与此同时，对灵顿街10号的搜查正在进行中。
Police examined the garden for recently disturbed earth, but found nothing. In the ground floor flat belonging to John and Ethel Christie, police found Geraldine's clothing, pram and high chair. The Evans' upstairs flat was empty of furniture, but four newspaper clippings were discovered. They detailed a notorious crime that had taken place earlier that autumn. On October 4, 1949, Stanley Setty, a wealthy car dealer from London's East End, disappeared. Nearly three weeks later, his torso was found in a marsh in the nearby county of Essex. A 29-year-old named Brian Hume was later charged with the murder. The clippings included pictures of the bundle that Stanley's torso had been wrapped in.
警察检查了花园里最近被翻动过的泥土，但一无所获。在约翰和埃塞尔·克里斯蒂夫妇的地铺公寓里，警方找到了杰拉丁的衣服、婴儿车和高脚椅。埃文斯楼上的公寓里没有家具，但发现了四篇剪报。它们详细记录了那年秋天早些时候发生的一起轰动一时的罪案。1949年10月4日，伦敦东区的一位富有汽车经销商斯坦利·塞蒂失踪了。近三 weeks 后，他的躯干在附近埃塞克斯郡的一个沼泽里被发现。一名29岁名叫布赖恩·休姆的男子随后被指控谋杀。剪报中包括了包裹斯坦利躯干的包裹的照片。
Officers also found a briefcase that had been stolen in August from a residential Notting Hill address, enabling them to arrest Timothy Evans for grand larceny. By the morning of Friday, December 2, more than 36 hours had passed since Timothy Evans had given his initial confession, yet police still hadn't found Beryl or Geraldine. Timothy remained insistent that John Christie had killed Beryl and had knowledge of Geraldine's whereabouts, but John staunchly denied these claims. By this stage, Chief Detective Inspector George Jennings had been placed in charge of the case. Another officer and a biologist from Scotland Yard joined him in a thorough search of Tan-Rillington Place.
警员们还找到了一只 briefcase，该公文包是8月份从诺丁汉的一处住宅地址被盗的，这使得他们能够以重大盗窃罪逮捕蒂莫西·埃文斯。到12月2日星期五早上，距离蒂莫西·埃文斯最初供认已经过去了36个多小时，然而警察仍然没有找到贝瑞尔或杰拉丁。蒂莫西坚称约翰·克里斯蒂杀害了贝瑞尔，并且知道杰拉丁的下落，但约翰坚决否认这些说法。此时，侦探总督察乔治·詹宁斯已被任命为该案的负责人。另一名警官和苏格兰场的生物学家与他一起对坦-里灵顿广场进行了彻底搜查。
The house was again checked from top to bottom, but resulted in no significant discoveries. They went into the communal backyard next, finding a broken dustbin that didn't garner their interest. They searched the outdoor lavatory before turning their attention to the small wash house that had joined it, though the door stuck shut. Ethel Christie, who was observing the goings-on with her husband, explained that the door had a habit of jamming and fetched a knife which was used to prise it open. It was so dark inside that the officers needed a torch to see. The wash house measured just 54 by 52 inches and was primarily used for storage or fetching water. There was a copper boiler in the left corner and to the right was a sink with a pile of timber boards stacked against it.
这所房子再次被彻底搜查了一遍，但没有取得任何重大发现。接下来，他们进入了隔壁的公共后院，发现了一个破损的垃圾桶，这并没有引起他们的兴趣。他们搜查了室外厕所，随后将注意力转向了与之相连的小洗衣房，但门卡死了。正和丈夫一起观察进展的埃塞尔·克里斯蒂解释说，这门有卡壳的习惯，并取来了一把用来把它撬开的刀。里面太黑了，警官们需要手电筒才能看清。洗衣房只有54乘52英寸大小，主要用于储藏或取水。左角有一个铜锅炉，右边是一个水槽，旁边堆着一堆木板。
Chief Detective Inspector Jennings reached behind the wood pile and felt something. He removed some of the boards and uncovered something wrapped in a green tablecloth and tied with a cotton sash cord. He asked Ethel what was in it, but she had never seen it before. The officers laid the bundle on the cement outside the wash house. As they did so, a pair of feet that were bound together slipped out. Detective Jennings returned to the wash house and spotted something else hidden behind some wood stacked behind the door. It was the body of a baby girl with a man's tie knotted around her neck. You could be sitting in the perfect Airbnb spot right now.
侦探总督察詹宁斯把手伸到木堆后面，摸到了一些东西。他移开了一些木板，发现了一个用绿色桌布包裹着、用棉质饰带绳捆绑的东西。他问埃塞尔里面是什么，但她从未见过这东西。警官们将这个包裹放在洗衣房外的水泥地上。当他们这样做时，一对绑在一起的脚滑了出来。侦探詹宁斯回到洗衣房，发现门后堆放的木头后面还藏着别的东西。那是一个女婴的尸体，脖子上系着一条男士领带。你现在可能正坐在完美的爱彼迎住所里。
If you have a spare bedroom, which is such a fun way to meet new people from around the world, if you're hosting them, why not make some extra money off of it? Or if you're always traveling like I am, it's so easy to just Airbnb your whole place. I was out of town for four months out of the year last year with a vacant condo just sitting there not being used. And I've realized how easy it would be to make extra money in the side to cover all of my travel costs when I'm away just by becoming an Airbnb host. When I'm traveling the world, I almost exclusively stay in Airbnb's because I like having access to a kitchen, feeling like I'm at home when I'm traveling, having all the stuff that you would normally have when you're at home.
如果你有一间空闲的卧室，这不仅是结识来自世界各地的新朋友的有趣方式，如果你接待他们，为什么不从中赚取一些外快呢？或者如果你像我一样经常旅行，把你的整个房子都爱彼迎出去是如此简单。去年我有四个月不在城里，空置的公寓就那样闲置着不用。我意识到通过成为一名爱彼迎房东，在业余时间赚取外快来支付我外出时的所有旅行费用是多么容易。当我环游世界时，我几乎只住在爱彼迎里，因为我喜欢可以使用厨房，旅行时有在家的感觉，拥有你在家里通常会拥有的所有东西。
And I love the local recommendation guides that a lot of hosts provide, so you can just get to know the area that you're visiting from someone who's actually lived in it. I just used Airbnb actually in Tulum to stay at truly the most luxurious penthouse loft I have ever seen. It was such a vibe, the aesthetic was incredible, the service was fantastic, and I loved the privacy of it. Airbnb is such a smart way to use what you already have to generate more income, whether you're saving for a wedding or a big trip somewhere, or just trying to cover bills and passively bump up your income. Your home might be worth more than you think.
我喜欢许多房东提供的当地推荐指南，这样你可以通过一个真正住在那里的人来了解你正在访问的地区。我实际上刚刚在图卢姆使用了爱彼迎，住在我见过的最豪华的顶层公寓阁楼里。那种氛围太棒了，美学令人难以置信，服务非常棒，我喜欢它的私密性。爱彼迎是利用你现有的东西来创造更多收入的明智方式，无论你是在为婚礼或某个地方的大旅行存钱，还是只是想支付账单并被动地增加收入。你的家可能比你想象的更值钱。
So find out how much at Airbnb.ca slash host. The large, bound parcel contained the body of 19-year-old Beryl Evans, bent with her head between her feet. The infant body was that of her one-year-old daughter, Geraldine. As the weather in London had been cold in recent weeks, both corpses were preserved and had no foul odor. Beryl and Geraldine had been deceased for roughly three weeks, and the cause of death in both cases was asphyxiation by strangulation. Ligature marks and bruises on Beryl's throat and neck were consistent with her killer using a piece of rope or twisted stocking.
所以请在 Airbnb.ca slash host 上了解具体价值。那个大的、被捆绑的包裹里装着19岁的贝瑞尔·埃文斯的尸体，身体弯曲，头部夹在双脚之间。婴儿的尸体是她一岁女儿杰拉丁的。由于伦敦最近几周天气寒冷，两具尸体都得到了保存，没有恶臭。贝瑞尔和杰拉丁已经去世大约三周，两起案件的死因都是勒颈窒息。贝瑞尔喉咙和颈部的勒痕和瘀伤与凶手使用绳子或扭曲的长筒袜一致。
She was dressed in a skirt, blouse and jacket, with the latter two undone, exposing her upper body. Her underwear was missing. Her face was bruised with her right eye and upper lip both swollen, indicating that she'd been struck about 20 minutes before her death. Beryl also had two bruises on her upper left thigh, one on her left shin, and another small bruise inside her vaginal wall. Her womb contained a 16-week-old male fetus and bore no signs of the work of an amateur abortionist. It was believed that the bruise in her vagina might have been from a self-inflicted injury done to induce a miscarriage,
她身穿裙子、衬衫和夹克，后两件未扣，露出了上半身。她的内衣不见了。她的面部有瘀伤，右眼和上唇都肿胀，表明她在死前大约20分钟遭到过击打。贝瑞尔的左大腿上部还有两处瘀伤，左小腿有一处，阴道壁内还有一处小瘀伤。她的子宫里有一个16周大的男胎，没有业余堕胎手术的迹象。人们认为她阴道内的瘀伤可能是为了引发流产而造成的自残性损伤，
yet the possibility that her killer had attempted to sexually assault her post-mortem was also considered. Geraldine Evans was fully clothed. Her only injuries were ligature marks on her neck, caused by the tie found with her remains. The pair's clothing was identified by John and death or Christie, who confirmed the items had belonged to their neighbors. When shown the tie used to kill Geraldine, John thought he might have seen Timothy Evans wearing one quite similar. Timothy Evans was transported from Mertha Tidville back to London so that he could be formally charged with the murder of Beryl and Geraldine. Without telling him that the bodies of his wife and daughter had been found, the officers escorted Timothy on a train to London that night. A police tip-off alerted the media, and a press photographer was waiting as the train pulled in at Paddington Station.
然而，凶手曾试图对其实施死后性侵的可能也被考虑在内。杰拉丁·埃文斯衣着完整。她唯一的伤是脖子上的勒痕，是由与她的遗体一起找到的那条领带造成的。两人的衣服由约翰和（死亡或）克里斯蒂辨认，他们证实这些物品属于他们的邻居。当被出示用于杀害杰拉丁的领带时，约翰认为他可能见过蒂莫西·埃文斯戴过一条非常相似的。蒂莫西·埃文斯被从默瑟蒂德维尔押回伦敦，以便对他正式提出谋杀贝瑞尔和杰拉丁的指控。在没有告诉他他的妻子和女儿的尸体已经被找到的情况下，警官们当晚护送蒂莫西乘坐火车前往伦敦。警方的一条线索惊动了媒体，当火车驶入帕丁顿车站时，一名摄影记者正在那里守候。
They snapped a picture of a startled and distraught Timothy as he disembarked, flanked by two officers. He was taken to Notting Hill Police Station, where he was placed in the charge room. Layed out on the floor were the items recovered from Beryl and Geraldine's bodies, including their clothing, the blanket, tablecloth and cord used to wrap Beryl's body, and the knotted tie used to strangle Geraldine. As Timothy surveyed the items, Chief Detective Inspector George Jennings stated, At 11.50 today I found the dead body of your wife, Beryl Evans, concealed in a wash house at 10 Rillington Place, Notting Hill. Also, the body of your baby daughter, Geraldine, concealed behind some timber in the same outbuilding, and this clothing was found with them. Tears appeared in Timothy's eyes. As he picked up the tie, Detective Jennings informed him that his wife and daughter had been strangled to death, and that he had reason to believe Timothy was responsible. Timothy replied, Yes.
他们拍下了一张惊恐而心烦意乱的蒂莫西的照片，当时他正走下车，两侧由两名警官陪同。他被带到诺丁汉警察局，并被安置在值班室里。地板上摆放着从贝瑞尔和杰拉丁的尸体上回收的物品，包括她们的衣服、用于包裹贝瑞尔尸体的毯子、桌布和绳子，以及用于勒死杰拉丁打结的领带。当蒂莫西审视这些物品时，侦探总督察乔治·詹宁斯说道：“今天11点50分，我在诺丁汉10号里灵顿广场的一个洗衣房里发现了你妻子贝瑞尔·埃文斯的尸体。此外，还有你的女婴杰拉丁的尸体，藏在同一个附属建筑的一些木材后面，这些衣服是在她们身边找到的。”蒂莫西的眼中泛起了泪光。当他拿起领带时，詹宁斯侦探告诉他，他的妻子和女儿是被勒死的，并且他有理由相信蒂莫西应该对此负责。蒂莫西回答说：“是的。”
Timothy immediately provided a brief, verbal confession to the crimes, which Detective Jennings transcribed into his notebook. It read, Beryl was incurring one death after another. I could not stand it any longer, so I strangled her with a piece of rope, and took her down to the flat below the same night, whilst the old man was in hospital. I waited till the Christie's downstairs had gone to bed, then I took her to the wash house after midnight. This was on Tuesday 8th November. On Thursday evening, after I came home from work, I strangled my baby in our bedroom with my tie, and later that night I took her down into the wash house after the Christie's had gone to bed. When Timothy signed this confession, he allegedly told the officers he felt a great relief at finally sharing the truth, before offering to go into more detail about the crimes. He then provided another, more detailed statement, his fourth since turning himself in to police two days earlier. He described murdering Beryl around 6.30 on the evening of Tuesday, November 8, after she initiated a dispute that quickly became physical.
蒂莫西立即对这些罪行作出了简短的口头供述，詹宁斯侦探将其记录在笔记本中。上面写着：“贝瑞尔接连不断地找死。我再也忍受不下去了，所以我用一根绳子勒死了她，并在当晚老头子住院时，把她带到了楼下的公寓里。我等到楼下的克里斯蒂夫妇上床睡觉后，在午夜过后把她带到了洗衣房。这是在11月8日星期二。星期四晚上，我下班回家后，在我们的卧室里用我的领带勒死了我的孩子，那天晚些时候，在克里斯蒂夫妇上床睡觉后，我把她带到了洗衣房。”据称，当蒂莫西签署这份口供时，他告诉警官们，终于说出真相让他感到一阵巨大的解脱，随后他主动提出要更详细地描述这些罪行。接着他提供了另一份更详细的陈述，这是他自两天前向警方自首以来的第四份陈述。他描述了在11月8日星期二晚上6点30分左右谋杀贝瑞尔的经过，当时贝瑞尔挑起了一场争吵，很快演变成了肢体冲突。
Timothy hid her across the face, and Beryl retaliated. Quote, In a fit of temper, I grabbed a piece of rope from a chair which I had brought home off my van, and strangled her with it. I then took her into the bedroom and laid her on the bed, with the rope still tied around her neck. Before 10 that night, I carried my wife's body downstairs to the kitchen of Mr Kitchener's flat, as I knew he was away in hospital. He then fed Geraldine, put her to bed, and smoked a cigarette, before returning to Charles Kitchener's vacant flat to wrap Beryl's body in a blanket and green tablecloth. He bound her concealed body with cord from a kitchen cupboard, and carried her downstairs to the wash house. She was placed under the sink, with planks of wood stacked in front. Timothy then slipped back into the house, and spent the rest of the night lying fully dressed on his bed.
蒂莫西打了她的脸，贝瑞尔进行了反击。“引用：‘在一气之下，我从我从货车上带回家的一把椅子上抓起了一段绳子，并用它勒死了她。然后我把她带到卧室里，让她躺在床上，脖子上还系着绳子。在当晚10点之前，我把我妻子的尸体搬到楼下基奇纳先生公寓的厨房里，因为我知道他住院不在家。’然后他喂了杰拉丁，哄她睡觉，抽了一根烟，然后返回查尔斯·基奇纳空置的公寓，用毛毯和绿色桌布包裹贝瑞尔的尸体。他用厨房橱柜里的绳子把她隐藏的尸体捆绑起来，然后搬到楼下洗衣房。她被放在水槽下面，前面堆着木板。蒂莫西随后溜回屋里，在床上穿着衣服躺着度过了剩下的夜晚。”
Over the next two days, he fed and changed Geraldine before going to work, leaving her alone at the flat until he returned in the evenings. On Wednesday, November 10, he had an argument with his employer, and subsequently quit. Upon arriving home, he picked up Geraldine from her cot, and strangled her with one of his tires. After waiting for John and Ethel Christie to go to bed, he crept downstairs with the Geraldine's body, and hid her in the wash house as well. News of Evan's arrest broke quickly. On Saturday, December 3, two London papers published stories about his late night interrogation, with the evening standard running a headline that read, Man All Night with the Police. That same morning, Timothy was formally charged with murder, to which he replied,
在接下来的两天里，他喂养并照顾杰拉丁，然后去上班，把她独自留在公寓里，直到晚上回来。11月10日星期三，他和雇主发生了争执，随后辞职了。回到家后，他把杰拉丁从婴儿床里抱起来，用他的一条领带勒死了她。在等待约翰和埃塞尔·克里斯蒂上床睡觉后，他带着杰拉丁的尸体蹑手蹑脚地走到楼下，也将她藏在了洗衣房里。埃文斯被捕的消息迅速传开。12月3日星期星期六，两家伦敦报纸发表了关于他深夜审讯的报道，《伦敦晚报》的头条标题是：“与警方共度一夜的男子”。当天早上，蒂莫西被正式指控谋杀，他对此回答说：
Yes, that's right. He was transported to Brixton Prison in London's Inner South to await trial. Upon admission, he confessed to the prison's principal medical officer, who was required to ascertain whether he was sane and mentally competent to stand trial. For reasons unknown, Beryl's father and siblings were not given details regarding her and Geraldine's funeral. Authorities arranged for the mother and daughter to be laid to rest in a shared grave, known as a porpoise grave, alongside six other bodies. Their burial site was located in the Catholic section of London's Gunnersbury Cemetery, despite Beryl being of Jewish faith. In the days that followed, investigators set about building a case for the prosecution. They revisited 10 Rillington Place on Monday, December 5, to obtain a more detailed statement from residents John and Ethel Christie.
“是的，没错。”他被押送到伦敦南部内陆的布里克斯顿监狱等待审判。入狱后，他向监狱的首席医疗官坦白，该医疗官负责确定他是否精神健全且具有接受审判的精神能力。由于不明原因，贝瑞尔的父亲和兄弟姐妹没有得到关于她和杰拉丁葬礼的细节。当局安排这对母女安葬在一个与其他六具尸体共用的坟墓中，被称为鼠海豚墓。她们的埋葬地点位于伦敦冈纳斯伯里公墓的天主教区，尽管贝瑞尔信仰犹太教。在接下来的几天里，调查人员开始为起诉构建案件。他们于12月5日星期一重返里灵顿广场10号，以从居民约翰和埃塞尔·克里斯蒂那里获得更详细的陈述。
Both reported hearing heavy thudding from above on the night of November 8, as though someone were moving furniture. In relation to the backyard wash house, Ethel told police that they locked its door each night. However, there was no lock on the door, with residents merely jamming it shut in a manner that made it difficult to open. As the room's boiler was broken, the space was typically used for storage. Ethel had been using it daily since November 8 to rinse out a bedpan and saw the pile of timber stacked in front of the sink, but didn't notice anything tucked behind it. John Christie didn't visit the wash house until Monday, November 14, the date Timothy Evans left for Wales. At 7.30 that morning, John ventured out to fetch some firewood. He entered the wash house and noticed the timber pile, but didn't disturb it.
两人都报告说，在11月8日晚上听到楼上有沉重的脚步声，就像有人在搬家具一样。关于后院洗衣房，埃塞尔告诉警察，他们每天晚上都锁上门。然而，门上并没有锁，居民们只是以一种很难打开的方式将门卡死。由于房间的锅炉坏了，这个空间通常用作储藏室。自11月8日以来，埃塞尔每天都使用它来冲洗便盆，并看到了堆在水槽前的木材堆，但没有注意到藏在后面的任何东西。约翰·克里斯蒂直到11月14日星期一蒂莫西·埃文斯离开去威尔士的那天才去洗衣房。那天早上7点30分，约翰冒险出去取一些柴火。他进入洗衣房，注意到了木材堆，但没有动它。
The day before Beryl was murdered, she spoke to Ethel about a friend named Joan Vincent coming to visit. Beryl was less than enthused, accusing the woman of causing trouble between herself and Timothy. Joan was one of Beryl's oldest friends, having met in school when they were children. They lost touch, only to reconnect after a chance meeting at a post-ponatal clinic where they took their infant daughters. The two women would catch up several times a week, taking it in turns to visit one another. Joan told police that she couldn't quite recall when she had last visited Beryl, naming November 5, 7 and 8 as possible dates. Joan arrived at 10 Rillington Place around lunchtime. The building's front door was open, something she had never seen before.
在贝瑞尔被谋杀的前一天，她和埃塞尔谈起了一个叫琼·文森特的朋友要来探望。贝瑞尔表现得不太热心，指责这个女人在自己和蒂莫西之间制造麻烦。琼是贝瑞尔最老的朋友之一，她们小时候在学校就认识了。后来她们失去了联系，直到在一家产后诊所偶然相遇后才重新联系上，当时她们带着各自的女婴。这两个女人一周会聚好几次，轮流去对方家里。琼告诉警察，她记不清自己最后一次拜访贝瑞尔是什么时候，说11月5日、7日和8日都有可能。琼在午饭时间左右到达里灵顿广场10号。这栋建筑的前门是开着的，这是她以前从未见过的。
She went upstairs and found the door to the Evans' flat, which was usually kept open, closed. She knocked and called out, Beryl, it's me. There was no answer, which Joan found odd as Beryl was always home at lunchtime. She attempted to open the door by turning the handle. It gave slightly before closing again as though someone were pushing against it. Convinced there was somebody standing on the other side, Joan said, If you don't want to see me, you've only got to say so. There was no reply, so Joan left.
她上楼发现埃文斯家平时敞开的门关着。她敲门并喊道：“贝瑞尔，是我。”没有人回答，琼觉得这很奇怪，因为贝瑞尔午饭时间总是在家。她试图通过转动把手开门。门稍微松动了一下，然后又关上了，好像有人在从里面推。琼确信里面有人站着，便说：“如果你不想见我，直说就行。”没有人回答，于是琼离开了。
In the course of their investigation, police discovered that around the time of Beryl's murder, structural work was underway at 10 Rillington Place. The landlord had hired a team of five laborers to repair plastering and replace floorboards. A manager, plasterer, carpenter and two assistants commenced work on Monday, October 31 and were at the property on and off over the next two weeks. Repair work on the roof of the outdoor wash house and lavatory commenced on Tuesday, November 8. Plasterer Frederick Willis and his assistant Frederick Jones left the building's front door open as they were constantly entering and exiting to gather equipment. At around 10am, Jones was mixing materials out front when a young woman came downstairs with a baby in her arms, accompanied by another young woman. She put the baby in a pram and left. He couldn't recall seeing her again. The plasterers finished mending the wash house ceiling by the following day and for the rest of the week were regularly in and out of the small building as they stored their tools in there.
在调查过程中，警方发现，在贝瑞尔被谋杀前后，里灵顿广场10号正在进行结构施工。房东雇佣了一个由五名工人组成的团队来修补灰泥和更换地板。一名经理、一名泥瓦匠、一名木匠和两名助手从10月31日星期一开始工作，并在接下来的两周里断断续续地在房产里工作。室外洗衣房和厕所屋顶的修缮工作于11月8日星期二开始。泥瓦匠弗雷德里克·威利斯和他的助手弗雷德里克·琼斯将房子的前门敞开，因为他们不断进出收集设备。大约上午10点，琼斯正在前台搅拌材料，一个年轻女子抱着一个婴儿下楼，由另一个年轻女子陪同。她把婴儿放进婴儿车里然后离开了。他记不起再次见过她。泥瓦匠在第二天之前完成了对洗衣房天花板的修缮，并且在接下来的那一周里，他们经常进出这个小建筑，因为他们把工具存放在那里。
When their work finished on Friday, November 11, Jones cleaned and swept the room thoroughly before leaving the property for good. Both men were certain there had been nothing out of the ordinary there during that period. All five workmen were shown a crime scene photograph of the wash house that depicted the timber pile by the sink. Carpenter Robert Anderson identified the planks as floorboards he had removed from the ground floor hallway on November 14. He left them in the wash house for the tenants to use as firewood. These statements were at odds with Timothy Evans' final confession. He had described placing the bodies of Beryl and Geraldine in the wash house on November 8 and November 10 respectively. Yet, the workmen had been accessing the small room on both those dates.
当他们的工作在11月11日星期五结束时，琼斯彻底清洁并打扫了房间，然后彻底离开了这处房产。两人都确信在此期间那里没有什么不寻常的事情。所有五名工人都被出示了一张洗衣房的犯罪现场照片，照片显示了水槽旁的木材堆。木匠罗伯特··安德森确认这些木板是他于11月14日从底层走廊拆除的地板。他把它们留在洗衣房里供租户当柴火使用。这些陈述与蒂莫西·埃文斯的最后一份口供相矛盾。他曾描述说分别于11月8日和11月10日将贝瑞尔和杰拉丁的尸体放置在洗衣房中。然而，工人们在这两个日期都曾进入过那个小房间。
Upon realizing this discrepancy, Chief Detective Inspector George Jennings summoned plasterer Frederick Willis and his assistant Frederick Jones to clarify matters, along with their manager Raymond Phillips. Detective Jennings asked Phillips to speak with him first while his two employees waited in another room. Three hours passed and Willis and Jones grew frustrated. Finally, Jones was brought in for questioning. Detective Jennings wasted no time in telling him that his earlier statement was incorrect, as the bodies had been placed in the wash house before he concluded his work there on November 11. Jones was certain this could not be the case, as he had not seen anything suspicious in the wash house the entire time he was at 10 Rillington Place. He was insistent, refusing to budge from his story. His boss, Raymond Phillips, was called into the room and told,
在意识到这种差异后，侦探总督察乔治·詹宁斯传唤了泥瓦匠弗雷德里克·威利斯和他的助手弗雷德里克·琼斯以及他们的经理雷蒙德·菲利普斯来澄清情况。詹宁斯侦探要求菲利普斯先跟他谈谈，而他的两名雇员则在另一个房间等待。三个小时过去了，威利斯和琼斯变得沮丧起来。最后，琼斯被带进来接受讯问。詹宁斯侦探毫不浪费时间地告诉他，他早先的陈述是不正确的，因为在他在11月11日结束那里的工作之前，尸体就已经被放进洗衣房了。琼斯确信情况绝非如此，因为他在里灵顿广场10号的整个时间里都没有在洗衣房里看到任何可疑的东西。他态度坚决，拒绝改变自己的说法。他的老板雷蒙德·菲利普斯被叫进房间并被告知：
We've got 30 or 40 witnesses to prove the bodies were in the wash house, but your man says they weren't. Phillips turned to Jones, pointing out that if the police said this was the case, then it must be so. Jones altered his statement, writing that he now recalled clearing out the wash house on Tuesday, November 8, not Friday, November 11. Frederick Willis was then asked to join them. He too began to doubt his own recollections and changed his statement, adding the words, I feel now that it would have been quite possible for anything to have been under the sink in the corner. An officer was dispatched to 10 Rillington Place to verify the amended details with the Christie's, who had become the primary witnesses in the case. John Christie confirmed that on Tuesday, November 8, the plasterers told him they had finished the repairs on the wash house and lavatory.
“我们有30或40名证人可以证明尸体在洗衣房里，但你的人说没有。”菲利普斯转向琼斯，指出如果警方这么说，那一定就是这样。琼斯修改了他的供词，写道他现在回想起是在11月8日星期二清理洗衣房的，而不是11月11日星期五。然后请弗雷德里克·威利斯加入他们。他也开始怀疑自己的记忆并修改了他的口供，并加上了这样的话：“我现在觉得角落水槽底下放点什么完全是有可能的。”一名警官被派往里灵顿广场10号，向克里斯蒂夫妇核实修改后的细节，克里斯蒂夫妇已成为此案的主要证人。约翰·克里斯蒂证实，在11月8日星期二，泥瓦匠告诉他他们已经完成了对洗衣房和厕所的维修。
He also clarified that they had stored their tools and materials in the front room of his flat from that date until November 11. Thomasina visited Brixton Prison to see her son. She had tried to visit him while he was under arrest, but was told she would have to wait until he'd been formally charged. Upon reuniting with him after weeks of no contact, Thomasina asked, Tim, why did you do it? He responded, I didn't do it mum, Christie done it. Before explaining that he hadn't even realized that Geraldine was dead until police brought him back to London.
他还澄清说，从那天起直到11月11日，他们一直将工具和材料存放在他公寓的前厅里。托马西娜前往布里克斯顿监狱探望她的儿子。她曾在他被捕期间试图探望他，但被告知必须等到他被正式起诉。在失联数周后与他重逢时，托马西娜问：“蒂姆，你为什么要这么做？”他回答说：“妈妈，我没有做，是克里斯蒂干的。”在解释说直到警察把他带回伦敦之前他甚至没有意识到杰拉丁已经死了之前。
Timothy claimed that police had interrogated him until five o'clock in the morning to coax a confession from him. He pleaded with his mother to have John Christie visit him, stating, He's the only one who can help me now. Timothy Evans was granted legal aid for his defense as he had no money to pay for an attorney. He continued to profess his innocence, though his legal team viewed his sworn statements as very damning. Their brief noted that it would be difficult to decide whether to try for an insanity defense or provide an alternative scenario in line with their client's claims. Timothy's barrister Malcolm Morris visited him in prison on a number of occasions. During these meetings, Timothy explained that he had been scared police would become violent with him if he didn't confess to the murders.
蒂莫西声称警察审讯他直到清晨五点才逼迫他招供。他恳求母亲让约翰·克里斯蒂去探望他，并说：“现在只有他能帮我了。”蒂莫西·埃文斯获得了法律援助来为自己辩护，因为他没有钱请律师。他继续坚称自己无罪，尽管他的法律团队认为他的宣誓供词非常不利。他们的简报指出，很难决定是尝试做精神失常辩护还是提供符合他们当事人说辞的替代方案。蒂莫西的大律师马尔科姆·莫里斯曾在监狱里多次探访他。在这些会面中，蒂莫西解释说，他曾担心如果自己不承认谋杀，警察会对施以暴力。
He reverted back to his second statement, blaming John Christie for killing Beryl, despite there being no evidence of her having undergone a botched abortion. He remarked that John must have killed Geraldine as well. Morris warned his client that the court probably wouldn't believe this version of events, and if he was to insist on it as his defense, then he would be required to testify. Timothy understood and readily agreed to do so. British legal practice at the time meant that even if a defendant was charged with multiple murders, they would only be prosecuted for one. Therefore, the prosecution had to decide whether to try Timothy Evans for the murder of Beryl or Geraldine.
他恢复了第二份供词，指责约翰·克里斯蒂杀害了贝瑞尔，尽管没有证据表明她曾接受过失败的流产手术。他谈到约翰一定也杀害了杰拉丁。莫里斯警告他的当事人，法庭可能不会相信这一版本的事件，如果他坚持以此作为辩护，那么他将需要出庭作证。蒂莫西表示理解并欣然同意这样做。当时的英国法律实践意味着，即使被告被控多起谋杀，也只会因其中一起被起诉。因此，控方必须决定是以谋杀贝瑞尔还是杰拉丁的罪名来审判蒂莫西·埃文斯。
In cases where two murders were tied together in a single event, evidence that related to the first murder could be given in a trial about the second, but not the other way around. After some consideration, they chose to proceed with trialling the accused for Geraldine's murder. This way, they could still enter evidence about Beryl's death into court, thus strengthening their case against him for the murder of Geraldine. The trial commenced on Wednesday, January 11, 1950, at the Central Criminal Court of England and Wales, commonly known as the Old Bailey. There was little media interest in the case, and it was barely covered by the daily papers. Before proceedings began at 1030, Timothy Evans' legal team were startled to learn that key witness for the prosecution, John Christie, had a criminal record. This was despite Chief Detective Inspector George Jennings stating that John's record was, quote, as white as the driven snow.
在两起谋杀案在单一事件中联系在一起的情况下，与第一起谋杀有关的证据可以在有关第二起谋杀的审判中提出，但反之则不然。经过一番考虑，他们选择继续对被告进行杰拉丁谋杀案的审判。通过这种方式，他们仍然可以将关于贝瑞尔死因的证据带入法庭，从而加强他们对他谋杀杰拉丁的指控。审判于1950年1月11日星期三在英格兰和威尔士中央刑事法院（通常被称为老贝利）开庭。媒体对该案兴趣不大，日报也几乎没有报道。在10点30分庭审开始前，蒂莫西·埃文斯的法律团队惊奇地得知，控方的关键证人约翰·克里斯蒂有犯罪记录。尽管侦探总督察乔治·詹宁斯曾声明约翰的记录是“洁白无瑕的”。
Three decades earlier in 1921, John Christie stole two money orders during his employment as a postman, leading to a three-month prison sentence. Three years later, he committed larceny twice and was again sent to prison. The same year, he and Ethel separated, and John struck up a new relationship with a woman he met in London named Maude. Five years later, he was convicted of assaulting Maude after striking her in the head with a cricket bat. He was sentenced to six months' hard labour. His final conviction was for stealing a car in 1933, for which he served another three months. The prosecution and police were satisfied that John Christie had since become an upstanding citizen, worthy of testifying on their behalf in a murder trial. Following the outbreak of World War II, he worked as a war reserve constable until his resignation in 1943.
三十年前的1921年，约翰·克里斯蒂在担任邮递员期间偷了两张汇票，导致他被判处三个月监禁。三年后，他两次犯下盗窃罪，并再次被送进监狱。同年，他和埃塞尔分居，约翰与他在伦敦遇到的一位名叫莫德的女子开始了新的恋情。五年后，他在用板球棒击打莫德头部后被判犯有袭击莫德罪。他被判处六个月的苦役。他的最后一次定罪是在1933年偷窃一辆汽车，为此他又服刑三个月。检方和警方对约翰·克里斯蒂此后已成为一名正直的公民、有资格在谋杀审判中为他们作证感到满意。第二次世界大战爆发后，他一直担任战时预备警察，直到1943年辞职。
He and wife Ethel had since reunited and had lived at 10 Grillington Place since 1938. Despite this, the defence regarded John Christie as an unreliable witness. When John was called to give evidence at trial, he gave detailed accounts of arguments he'd overheard between the evidences, painting their relationship as destructive. He claimed that on the evening of November 10, the night that the prosecution was alleging the accused had killed baby Geraldine, Timothy had arrived home, quote, extremely angry, upset, really wild. He told John that he had quit his job and was hoping to find a new one in Bristol, where Beryl and Geraldine supposedly were, and would be selling his furniture before leaving. Defence barrister Malcolm Morris cross-examined John, using the opportunity to share his defendants' explanation for both murders by stating, Well, Mr Christie, I've got to suggest to you, and I do not want there to be any misapprehension about it, that you are responsible for the death of Mrs Evans and the little girl.
他和妻子埃塞尔此后重聚，自1938年以来一直住在里灵顿广场10号。尽管如此，辩方仍将约翰·克里斯蒂视为不可靠的证人。当约翰被传唤在审判中作证时，他详细描述了他在证据之间无意中听到的争吵，将他们的关系描绘成具有破坏性的。他声称在11月10日晚上，即控方指控被告杀死小杰拉丁的那天晚上，蒂莫西到家时“极其愤怒、心烦意乱、非常疯狂”。他告诉约翰，他已经辞去了工作，希望能去布里斯托尔找一份新工作，贝瑞尔和杰拉丁据称就在那里，并打算在离开前卖掉他的家具。辩护大律师马尔科姆·莫里斯对约翰进行了交叉盘问，借此机会分享了被告对两起谋杀案的解释，他说：“好吧，克里斯蒂先生，我不得不向你提出，我不想对此产生任何误解，那就是你对埃文斯太太和小女孩的死负有责任。”
While he acknowledged that he had known about Beryl's unwanted pregnancy, John firmly denied suggesting that he could perform an abortion for her. When asked whether he owned any medical textbooks, John said he owned a St John's ambulance manual that included diagrams of the human body, but had never shown it to Timothy Evans. He called the accusation that he helped carry Beryl's body downstairs ridiculous, as he had been bedridden with severe back pain and information of the small intestine during the week in question. In a final attempt to undermine John's credibility, Morris concluded his cross-examination by addressing his prior convictions. Other witnesses for the prosecution included Ethel Christie, whose testimony matched that of her husband's, Timothy's aunt, Violet Lynch, and Dr Robert Tear, the pathologist who had performed the autopsies of Beryl and Geraldine. He described how the pair were killed by strangulation and made it clear that there was no evidence of damage to Beryl's uterus indicative of an abortion procedure. All four of Timothy Evans' confessions were read to the court. The defense aimed to discredit them and managed to find one unreliable aspect. According to an inspector who was present at the time Timothy provided his statements, chief detective inspector George Jennings mentioned where Beryl and Geraldine's bodies were found before Timothy provided that information himself.
虽然他承认自己知道贝瑞尔的不想要怀孕，但约翰坚决否认曾暗示自己可以为她实施堕胎。当被问及他是否拥有任何医学教科书时，约翰说他拥有一本圣约翰救护手册，其中包含人体图解，但从未将其展示给蒂莫西·埃文斯。他称有关他协助将贝瑞尔的尸体抬下楼的指控是荒谬的，因为在相关的一周里，他一直卧床不起，患有严重的背痛和小肠炎症。为了最后一次削弱约翰的可信度，莫里斯通过谈及他先前的定罪结束了他的交叉盘问。控方的其他证人包括埃塞尔·克里斯蒂，她的证词与她丈夫的吻合；蒂莫西的姑姑维奥莱特·林奇；以及对贝瑞尔和杰拉丁进行尸检的病理学家罗伯特·蒂尔医生。他描述了两人是如何被勒死致死的，并明确表示没有证据表明贝瑞尔的子宫受到损伤可以证明曾进行过堕胎手术。蒂莫西·埃文斯的四份口供全部在法庭上宣读。辩方的目标是抹黑它们，并成功找到了一个不可靠的方面。据一位在蒂莫西提供口供时在场的督察称，侦探总督察乔治·詹宁斯在蒂莫西自己提供该信息之前就提到了贝瑞尔和杰拉丁的尸体是在哪里被发现的。
The defense only had one witness, Timothy Evans. Timothy explained to the court that he had initially blamed a stranger he met in a cafe for Beryl's death in order to protect John Christie. Upon learning that her body wasn't in the storm drain as he believed it would be, he had decided to tell the truth. He described his latter two confessions as a load of lies that he'd made up because he was destroyed at learning of Geraldine's death and believed police would knock him about if he didn't comply. He stated that when police showed him his wife and daughter's clothing and the other artifacts found with their bodies, they also revealed that the pair had been in the wash house concealed by timber. In his final question to his client, Malcolm Morris asked, Had you anything left to live for when Geraldine was dead? Timothy replied, No sir. Prosecutor Christmas Humphries referred to the defendants' known and extensive history of lying. He described to John Christie, a World War I veteran who also worked in the War Reserve police during World War II as a perfectly innocent man who had no motive to murder his neighbors.
辩方只有一名证人，即蒂莫西·埃文斯。蒂莫西向法庭解释说，他最初为了保护约翰·克里斯蒂，将贝瑞尔的死归咎于他在咖啡馆遇到的一個陌生人。在得知她的尸体不在他以为的雨水渠中后，他决定说出真相。他将后两份口供描述为他编造的一堆谎言，因为他在得知杰拉丁的死讯时感到崩溃，并相信如果他不服从，警察会殴打他。他表示，当警察向他展示他的妻子和女儿的衣服以及随尸体发现的其他物品时，他们还透露说这两人一直在被木材遮挡的洗衣房里。在对他当事人的最后一个问题中，马尔科姆·莫里斯问：“当杰拉丁死后，你还有什么活下去的理由吗？”蒂莫西回答说：“没有，先生。”检察官克리스마스·汉弗里斯提到了被告已知且广泛的撒谎历史。他将约翰·克里斯蒂描述为一名一战老兵，在二战期间也在战时预备警察中工作过，是一个完全无辜的人，没有动机谋杀他的邻居。
Humphries asked the defendant, Can you suggest why he should have strangled your wife? Can you suggest why he should have strangled your daughter? To both of these questions, Timothy replied, No. At the conclusion of his 10 minute long closing argument, Humphries asked the jury. Even if Christie had been responsible for the woman's death, why should he two days later go up to that flat and strangle an innocent little baby lying there aged 14 months? Even this fluent liar, who will lie as and when he pleases, cannot invent an answer to that question. The defense's closing argument was significantly longer. Malcolm Morris reminded the jury that unlike John Christie, Timothy Evans had no previous convictions for violent behavior.
汉弗里斯问被告：“你能解释一下他为什么要勒死你的妻子吗？你能解释一下他为什么要勒死你的女儿吗？”对于这两个问题，蒂莫西都回答：“没有。”在他长达10分钟的结案陈词结束时，汉弗里斯质问陪审团。即使克里斯蒂应对女人的死负责，为什么他两天后要走到那个楼上去勒死一个躺在那里的、14个月大的无辜婴儿呢？甚至连这个能随时随地随心所欲说谎的流畅骗子，也无法为这个问题编造出一个答案。辩方的结案陈词要长得多。马尔科姆·莫里斯提醒陪审团，与约翰·克里斯蒂不同，蒂莫西·埃文斯没有暴力行为的前科。
He asserted that elements of his client's story were not something that an uneducated illiterate man could invent. He explained that his client made no admissions that Geraldine was dead until after he was told her body had been found, at which point he confessed due to his fear of the police. The trial judge reminded the jury that they were only required to reach a verdict regarding Geraldine Evans' murder. Despite the defense's story that Beryl had died after arranging for John Christie to perform an abortion, the judge clarified that she had not died from such a procedure and added, Evans is a person who does not hesitate to lie. The jury deliberated for 40 minutes before returning with their verdict. They found Timothy Evans guilty of the murder of his one-year-old daughter Geraldine. In 1950, death was the mandatory sentence for murder. When asked if he had anything to say as to why the court should not sentence him to death, Timothy replied,
他断言，他当事人故事中的某些元素不是一个受教育程度不高的文盲能够凭空捏造的。他解释说，直到被告知杰拉丁的尸体被找到后，他的当事人并没有承认杰拉丁已经死亡，在那个时候，他因为害怕警察而供认了。审判法官提醒陪审团，他们只需要就杰拉丁·埃文斯谋杀案达成裁决。尽管辩方称贝瑞尔是在安排约翰·克里斯蒂进行堕胎后死亡的，但法官澄清说她并非死于此类手术，并补充说：“埃文斯是一个毫不犹豫地撒谎的人。”陪审团经过40分钟的审议后作出了裁决。他们裁定蒂莫西·埃文斯谋杀他一岁的女儿杰拉丁罪名成立。在1950年，死刑是谋杀罪的强制性判决。当被问及他是否有话要说，以说明法院不应判处他死刑时，蒂莫西回答：
No, sir. He remained silent as the judge stated. Timothy John Evans, the jury has found you guilty of willful murder and the sentence of the court upon you is that you be taken from this place to a lawful prison and thence to a place of execution and there you shall suffer death by hanging. May the Lord have mercy on your soul. At these words, John Christie broke into sobs from his seat at the back of the courtroom. As the Christie stood to leave, Timothy's mother shouted at John, Murderer, Murderer. Ethel replied, Don't you dare call my husband a murderer. He's a good man. Timothy Evans was taken to Pentonville Prison in North London to await his execution.
“没有，先生。”当法官宣判时，他保持沉默：“蒂莫西·约翰·埃文斯，陪审团裁定你故意谋杀罪名成立，本法院对你的判决是，将你从这个地方带到合法的监狱，然后再带到行刑地点，在那里你将遭受绞刑处死。愿上帝怜悯你的灵魂。”听到这些话，约翰·克里斯蒂在法庭后排的座位上失声痛哭。正当克里斯蒂起身离开时，蒂莫西的母亲向约翰大喊：“杀人犯！杀人犯！”埃塞尔回答说：“你竟敢叫我丈夫杀人犯。他是个好人。”蒂莫西·埃文斯被带到伦敦北部的本顿维尔监狱等待执行死刑。
He was a model prisoner who was generally liked by the guards. One officer noted that Timothy talked of his deceased wife and child, almost as if he had forgotten the crime. While another commented, he speaks of his wife with respect. Timothy passed time playing cards with other prisoners or discussing football and boxing. He found renewed faith in the Catholicism he had been raised with and attended mass every week while also receiving regular visits from a priest. His mother, stepfather and sisters visited often. Timothy continued to maintain his innocence. A month after his trial, he appealed his conviction on several grounds, including that evidence relating to Beryl's death should have been inadmissible and that the judge had misdirected the jury to find him guilty.
他是一个模范囚犯，普遍受到看守的喜爱。一名警官指出，蒂莫西谈论他去世的妻子和孩子时，几乎就像他已经忘记了这起罪行一样。而另一位则评论说：“他带着敬意谈论他的妻子。”蒂莫西通过与其他囚犯打牌或讨论足球和拳击来打发时间。他在从小养成的天主教信仰中找到了新的信念，每周都去望弥撒，同时也定期接受神父的探访。他的母亲、继父和姐妹们经常来探望。蒂莫西继续坚称自己无罪。审判一个月后，他以多种理由对定罪提出上诉，包括与贝瑞尔死因相关的证据本应不可采纳，以及法官对陪审团做出了有罪推定的误导指控。
His appeal was ultimately dismissed. Once again, Timothy showed no visible distress at the verdict, but upon returning to prison, he began pacing in his cell. His execution was scheduled for Thursday, March 9, 1950. Five days beforehand, Timothy appeared before a medical board to confirm he was of sound mind. He again attempted to recant his confessions, stating, I didn't care what happened to them, so I made the statement. He speculated that John Christie had killed Geraldine to get her out of the way. He didn't dwell on his situation, but found it painful to discuss.
他的上诉最终被驳回。蒂莫西对判决再次没有表现出明显的痛苦，但在返回监狱后，他开始在牢房里踱步。他的死刑定于1950年3月9日星期四执行。五天前，蒂莫西出现在一个医疗委员会面前以确认他精神健全。他再次试图推翻自己的供词，并表示：“我不在乎他们会发生什么，所以我作出了那份口供。”他推测约翰·克里斯蒂杀害杰拉丁是为了把她弄走。他没有纠结于自己的处境，但发现讨论这些很痛苦。
The board found no cause to provide a medical reprieve. Two days before his execution, Timothy was visited by his mother and sisters. He asked them if there was any hope, and his mother replied, We have done all we can, son. There's nothing more. I want you to make your peace with God. Don't worry, you'll go to heaven. At their final visit, Timothy's older sister, Eileen, stayed behind after the others had left and said, Look, Tim, you've got nothing to lose now. Tell me the truth so that I can know. Did you do it? He answered, No, Eileen, I didn't do it. Christie done it. On Thursday, March 9, 1950, Timothy spoke with a priest before the executioner arrived at 9 a.m.
委员会没有发现给予医学暂缓执行的理由。在他被执行死刑前两天，蒂莫西的母亲和姐妹们来探望了他。他问她们是否还有希望，他的母亲回答说：“我们已经尽力了，孩子。没有别的了。我要你与上帝讲和。别担心，你会上天堂的。”在他们最后一次探访时，蒂莫西的大姐艾琳在其他人离开后留了下来，并说：“听着，蒂姆，你现在没有什么可失去的了。告诉我真相，以便让我知道。是你干的吗？”他回答说：“没有，艾琳，不是我干的。是克里斯蒂干的。”1950年3月9日星期四，蒂莫西在上午9点行刑官到达之前与一位神父交谈。
He was taken to the prison's execution shed, where a hood was placed over his head, and he was hanged. His body was buried in an unmarked grave in the grounds of Pentonville Prison. The execution failed to make headlines. Five months later, the owner of 10 Rillington Place sold the house to a 35-year-old Jamaican immigrant. By this stage, Charles Kitchener had permanently vacated the property, and the building's new landlord planned to lease each of the rooms in the middle and upper floor flats to maximize returns. Seven new tenants moved in, four of whom were also from Jamaica. John and Ethel Christie remained in their ground floor residence, though they were displeased by their new neighbors. The pair held racist views and made a number of complaints about noise and intrusions to their property to a free legal advice service. Eventually, John Christie negotiated exclusive access to the property's backyard on the grounds that he and his wife needed privacy.
他被带到监狱的行刑棚，头上被套上头罩，随后被绞死。他的尸体被埋在本顿维尔监狱内的一个无名墓穴中。这次行刑并未引起轰动。五个月后，里灵顿广场10号的房主将这座房子卖给了一位35岁的牙买加移民。此时，查尔斯·基奇纳已永久搬离该房产，这栋建筑的新房东计划将中层和顶层公寓的每个房间出租，以实现利润最大化。七名新房客搬了进来，其中四人也来自牙买加。约翰和埃瑟尔·克里斯蒂夫妇仍住在底楼的住宅中，尽管他们对新邻居很不满。这对夫妇抱有种族偏见，曾向一家免费法律咨询服务机构就噪音和对其财产的侵扰提出多次投诉。最终，约翰·克里斯蒂以他和妻子需要隐私为由，协商获得了该房产后院的独家使用权。
By Tuesday, March 24, 1953, the Christie's were no longer living at 10 Rillington Place. That afternoon, Beresford Brown, the tenant who now occupied the top floor flat, was making some repairs to the Christie's old kitchen after the landlord had given him permission to make use of it. As he installed some brackets for a wireless radio, he tapped a portion of the room's rear wall and discovered that it was hollow. Beresford peeled back a small portion of wallpaper, revealing a small, hidden alcove tucked away alongside the kitchen. He shone a torch inside and was alarmed at what he saw. Tobay continued. Next week. Copyright© OSHO International Foundation There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到了1953年3月24日星期二，克里斯蒂夫妇已经不再住在里灵顿广场10号了。那天下午，现在居住在顶层公寓的房客贝雷斯福德·布朗在房东允许他使用克里斯蒂夫妇旧厨房后，正在对该厨房进行一些维修。当他安装收音机的支架时，他敲击了房间后墙的一部分，发现它是空的。贝雷斯福德剥开一小块壁纸，露出一个隐藏在厨房旁边的小壁龛。他把手电筒照进去，被眼前的景象吓坏了。故事未完待续。下周继续。版权所有© OSHO 国际基金会本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。